depuis dimanche elle est commentée elle
est disséqué l'abstention aux élections
départementales et régionales a battu
des records dans la région elle est
montée à plus de 63 % le taux le plus
haut jamais enregistré pour des
élections locales
alors de quoi cette abstention est elle
le reflet qu'en pensent les premiers
concernés
éléments de réponse avec le reportage de
sébastien manger si l'abstention a battu
un nouveau record lors des dernières
élections c'est encore plus vrai chez
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans selon l'ifop
ils sont 82% à ne pas avoir voté en
effet les jeunes expriment un désintérêt
encore plus profond voire un roger des
représentants politiques
c'est le cas de clément étudiant en
sociolinguistique à tour peu de raison
d'aller voter des lois pour les
régionales parce que ça va forcément des
réactions qui parle très importante et
en plus vu comment les problématiques
actuelles ont été soulevées ça donne pas
envie pour théotime 20 ans jeune
charpentier ce sont les parties dans
lesquelles il ne se reconnaît pas bah je
vois ce qui se passe politiquement leur
pays machin et ça me décourage un peu
quoi ses impressions je peux pas
vraiment faire confiance à ces gens là
qui prennent le pouvoir
je m'intéresserai bien à d'autres gens
qui viennent d'arriver dans le milieu
politique et qui veulent changer les
choses
sauf que on la leur ici au sanitas à
tours quartiers populaires l'abstention
bat aussi des records pour abdelmalek
c'est le manque de considération et
l'hypocrisie qui cimente son désintérêt
pour ces élections
pourtant entre guillemets ce qui fait la
force c'est qu'on est plus ou moins la
même situation et pour moi le s'occuper
plus du groupe et pas forcément de
l'individuel ça serait ce qu'il faudrait
faire surtout dans les quartiers
populaires en a pas se mentir on n'est
pas pris en considération on est
toujours en course et a raison quand ça
va mal mais l'argent mais on n'est pas
là quand ça va bien et pour masser
certaine hypocrisie vous demandez faire
quelque chose quand ça va bien
ce n'est pas nous les grands noms on va
mal même malaise pour sherman étudiants
en licence de langues étrangères
originaire de la rabière à joué les
tours qui pensent que généralement
globalement surtout les jeunes
ils ont peut-être le sentiment d'être un
peu les rejeter entre les dix mois de la
société surtout quand on vient d'un
quartier sensible je pense que c'est un
peu délicat
c'est souvent délicat politique est
jeune et les jeunes qui ont une
impression de de tout le temps à ne
servir à rien en fait c'est ça la classe
politique d'y entendre ce désintérêt des
jeunes pour les élections il ne leur
reste plus qu'à les écouter
cela pourrait peut-être changer les
choses